enron sunbeam global crossing and waste
management are some of the case studies
in Larry Elliott and Richard Strauss new
primer on misleading accounting
practices how companies lie next the
corporate strategist map out how
investors have been led astray and what
they should watch out for in the future
they also discuss their proposal to
create a Federal Insurance Fund to
reimburse investors who lose money as a
result of stock manipulation it's just
over an hour hi everyone I'm Carla Cohen
I'm one of the owners of politics and
prose and I'm delighted to welcome you
here today as um as I told Larry and
Richard the eye especially came back
from New York because I thought that
this was a such an interesting topic I
was in New York for the weekend and I
wanted to get back so I'm not my
microphones not on there you didn't miss
anything be I i think the topic is so
interesting and so timely and i was
particularly interested in how they
positioned their book to be published in
july of 2002 because what you don't know
but i know is it takes a full year to
publish a book normally and even these
instant books that are so called instant
books that are published are usually
books that have either the material is
has the reporter has been working on it
for a while or he's there's been a
series of articles errs and so on so the
the fact that they were poised and ready
to go and that when i read the
introduction almost every company that
we've heard about is mentioned in the
introduction and i said oh you must have
written this introduction in in you know
two months ago while they prepared the
book no no they said they'd written in a
long time ago so I had a little chance
to talk to these two gentlemen and to
ask them how this all came about and
what they said what they'll tell you
about it themselves these are two men
who've had 70 years of business
experience between them and there they
were well poised to see the in advance
that there was something amiss and there
was going to be some unraveling and they
had started to work on the book in fact
they told Richard told me that the book
was finished by September 11th and so I
guess that what's been happening since
then is some a few up datings here and
there so I'm really it's I think it's
you're in for a real treat when you hear
Larry Elliott and Richard Roth talk
about how companies lie why Enron is
just the tip of the iceberg it's only 70
years of experience if you depends on if
the author's lie or not and you can
figure out how to document that later on
today just as we will this Thank You
friends out there I see a lot of and
also a lot of folks who have come to
join us today we're actually going to do
two introductions Larry's going to do a
lil introduction I'm going to do a
little introduction the book because we
have two different viewpoints of this
but when i look at this book I think of
it as the book of the instant okay
because it's small you know somebody
said gee got it out fast it's not
typical size then it's a book of the day
because it you start to read it a little
bit you get involved in a little bit
more then it becomes and by the way
Publishers Weekly now has it as the book
of the day was one of the 365 books they
chose this year then we have the book of
the week because as the week seems to
progress along more things you start
defining this book
start to be real and then it's become
kind of the book of the month although
it hasn't been out a month it only came
out in July a second and so we we don't
know what the book of the month is going
to feel like yet but the book of the
week was good then it may be the book of
the year because it actually benchmarks
for the first time the words lie and
company have been ever used together in
a book part of our research as we began
to look at how books have been written
with this potentially threatening
career-threatening title was that there
was none it does give you pause to think
for just a few moments given that
there's so many business books out there
none had used the word lies in
corporations Larry and I had to do a
process check with each other to make
sure that our careers were not intact to
go ahead and do that and then we have a
book of the decade and god I hope not I
really hope that what is in here is not
a decade worth of problems for us coming
up because if it is we're all in for a
very long retirement a very long period
of time of trying to cope with the
issues around the world so that's my
quick perspective of the introduction
Larry you want to say a few things yeah
most of all we hope is the book you'll
buy so we can write another one in fact
we were kind of setting out on this
number two right now this was a great
fun project for us to do and we did
start this book over a year ago and we
had framed out what we saw coming and we
couldn't believe it ourselves to begin
with but we we did begin to believe
after we got deeper into the research I
think one of the things that it does
most well is that it really begins the
beginning of what I call a new investor
education program we're in a different
century in a different decade and we're
in a different kind of capital market
these days and investors are really
going to have to take on the
responsibility for learning more about
how these markets operate so part of the
responsibility that we've taken on we're
investors too and we were deeply
irritated by what was happening to our
market as we try to give in this book a
good picture of how to think about these
markets how to get inside the
boardrooms and to understand what goes
on from day to day and one of our
favorite parts is is helping you as
investors to figure out the rudest
questions you could possibly ask to your
financial planner or to your broker or
to the companies in which you have
invested your money we all know the
route is question Larry is are you going
to give my money back to me yes or have
you lied to me but it's a really a good
emphasis on the investor education
program I think the other part that we
concentrated on was to how to measure
whether or not real reform is taking
place our elected representatives have a
great opportunity last week to really
set the tone instead they chose to get
into a political brawl with each other
because of the election year it's been
very disappointing but there's some good
information in here and we don't want to
try to read the whole book to you want
to have some time for some good QA with
you about this but reform is the most
important next steps that we need to see
happen and we need to see an end to the
political rhetoric and we need to see
the beginning of some political action
that's what we hope for I think just to
start you out a little bit about how
Larry and I kind of came together to
write this it was actually this whole
book has been quite serendipity I mean
the fact the timing of it and such but
it was even more so at the very
beginning Larry and I met each other
about three years on an airplane ago
three years ago on an airplane how about
that one we were actually just flying
back from Boston and we started to talk
with each other about yoga actually in
the front seat and this conversation got
quite interesting because Larry was
practicing yoga and I was doing some
work in high performance neurofeedback
and so we started compare these two
things and we just found it fascinating
that we actually could send a whole trip
and it went by so fast that Larry and I
agree we should get together again and
so Larry went back to his office and
called me and said come analyst talk and
as we were doing that he said well why
don't you come work for me as a
consultant so I went to work with her
Larry and we started to play around with
some ideas and we started to get really
into the board decisions board
discussions what was going on at the
boardroom level of things then there was
a trip that I happen to be taking coming
back from Holland and I was reading a
newspaper and this was jeez I think this
was about februari of 2001 and there was
an article in the book a paper about a
company called L&H which was over in
Belgium and they make dragon naturally
speaking software and these two
particular CEOs of this company had
tremendous criminal record before they
became see I don't know how people get
promoted like this I'm still trying to
figure that that part of it out and they
had taken this company and just run it
into the ground and the stories went on
and on from kpmg who was there auditor
had transferred their head of auditing
to become the chief financial officer of
this company who then hired the next
chief auditor to come his assistant you
know and just this corruption and then
there was German spies in it and it was
a fascinating story and Larry you may
want to tell me about Johnny bondo and
how he got into this thing there's a
strange section in the book about Johnny
bondo a fictitious CEO we were trying to
have fun with this scenario that we saw
an LNA so he wrote a humorous little set
of chapters is called Johnny bondo
professional limo driver and johnny
banda was winding his way into this
situation and he was spying on the SEC
who said well this is a very interesting
little humorous little kind of paper
back here that we could sell we could
probably write this and people would buy
it and then we got to looking further
into the cases and we switched away from
the Johnny bondo into a more serious
vein rather quickly we got into the SEC
statistics we got into the court cases
and we said look at this and Arthur
Andersen has been sued seven times in a
row they paid 20 million dollar finds
several times in a row it's not in the
newspaper no one's talking about it all
the SEC statistics are up the number of
court cases the number of restatements
our revenues it's not in the newspaper
it's nowhere to be seen and that's that
kind of took us off on the trail then
some very serious research and so the
two guys we met on the airplane and
we're talking about yoga we're all of a
sudden talking about crime
it was it was pretty interested in fact
the Johnny bondo part you'll see
actually in the book there is a
fictitious part about what johnny has to
do as a potential fraudulent CEO to get
through all the lies in order to manage
it because it's not easy running a big
company and keeping those lies contained
I mean it's a lot of work it's not just
simple as we may think it is interesting
enough and this is the only final part
I'll say about Johnny bondo today the
independent which is in London the
newspaper ran a three quarter page ad of
the book it's going to be released in
two weeks in Europe and at a picture of
Jim Carrey with liar liar and it took
the only thing out of our book it took
was the quotes from Johnny bondo
executive limo driver and you may see
eventually a whole paperback series come
on that who knows that's an interesting
piece but as we started to go through
here there were four or five major
things that started to really appear to
us one of them was that not so much the
accounting issues although those were
pretty egregious and but they were being
settled out of court and most of the
public relations firms of most the
company's we're keeping that pretty
low-key I mean they were it would get up
in the newspaper about a day or two and
be gone and those things that get
settled and you never hear of them and
one of the reasons that you see so many
of the companies in the book is because
most these companies have a track record
this was didn't take a lot of
intelligence to go back and look into
the SEC records and find Xerox and
worldcom and all these companies who
have done this over and over again but
the problem was it was just moving
through the public relations machine and
just being dampen down yes I mean it's
true we it was pretty easy research once
we got into it but then we tried to
figure out the other side of the
equation you know what are the company's
going to have to do we have I think we
have one of our strongest chapters is
called dysfunctional governance where we
really are telling businesses including
the Board of Directors what they really
need to do in the boardroom in order to
get governance on the right track we
really talked about authenticity is
probably the next biggest form of
corporate asset companies are now trying
to
authenticity as a form of asset for the
corporation we have a lot to say about
how they should do that a thing called
performance reality is an actual
business methodology that we've invented
having written about it thoroughly in
the book but we certainly talked about
it a lot so there are management themes
there is a their investor education
themes throughout this book there's a
good mix of metaphor humor and so forth
irony satire you name it absolutely one
of the things that came out and we would
like you as you read this thing this
book has many layers to it at one layer
it can be pretty superficial gee these
guys jumped on the early bandwagon it
was really about an Ron and etc that's
not the case we were actually asked by
the publisher to go back as we had
finished this book and incorporate about
twenty percent of the book with enron
stories okay so it was never meant to be
an Enron book there will be other books
out that will go much deeper into the
Enron stories but what this book
actually in its best depth looks at it
started to look at that our companies
especially our big companies are
becoming so complex that they actually
are losing touch with their own reality
of what's there and when you hear people
say well only one percent of our maybe
our publicly traded companies are like
this well first of all one percent of
14,000 is still a hundred and forty and
nobody says those aren't the fortune 200
we don't know the the serious nature yet
of this thing secondly the technology's
piece is starting to play a very big
role in this as you read the technology
books like Gates's book on doing
business at the speed of light well this
is kind of lying at the speed of light
and there are many places where the
networks and such go much down much
deeper into round the world then we've
ever seen before and things that we've
never thought about that are hidden an
email that are hidden in our file
systems and etc are almost like the new
human genome if you will of the
corporation and in fact throughout the
book Larry and I talked about that there
needs to be a call for a new form of
management science that actually gets
beyond where we are right now
look at the next layer of business layer
it hasn't been discovered yet which is
part of this authenticity and it's not
just accounting it's in our legal
elements it's in our technology elements
in in all these elements that have to
begin to be looked at I think you know
the final the final thing I want to
mention again is the reform we have we
have some very specific reform
suggestions in here one of them to
handle people like inlay he was selling
in stalked when he told his workers not
to sell theirs is the thing called
executive escrow under the executive
escrow planned he could have sold the
stock proceeds would have been held in
escrow until the company was cleared and
he was cleared of any possibility of
wrongdoing there's a thing where we say
you want to really solve the conflict of
interest between the auditor and the
companies they work for then don't let
them work for the companies at all let
them be appointed and hard and served by
the SEC so we have a series of sharp
hitting reforms that we have in there
and you won't hear can hear Congress
talking about the kind of reform that we
have in there because ours our approach
is to get let's clean this up let's
really make this clear so people can
understand what's going on here but we
are waiting for the day we hope will be
soon when Harvey pit will stand up and
say I have a three to five year plan and
this plan is going to move us from a
failed policy model in terms of
securities regulation into a policy
model that works where you've integrated
the policy the rules of regulation the
accounting reform and the legal
infrastructure so we can really see
where we're going in the future until we
have that level of coherence rather than
its kind of legislative dart-throwing
that we see going on right now then we
should continue to be worried about
reform before I turn it over you for a
wrap up rich I just and we're going to
get into QA I just want to ask the first
question the company's lie in okay
survey complete well actually before we
do our little wrap-up I want you to
comment one other thing too there is
another reform that I thought was pretty
good in the book Larry and you can why
don't you explain to the folks on the
FDIC we talked about a a way to protect
investors against fraudulent situations
but still be able to be in the stock
market you want to just talking about
that was pretty pretty innovative after
the stock market crash of 29 and so
earth and because of the bank failures
they were going on during that period of
our history someone came of the idea for
the FDIC and when the FDIC was first
talked about people said this is the
most ridiculous idea we can imagine
having this kind of protection for banks
but we do have an FDIC and we are all
probably very glad that we have an FDIC
we describe the possibility of creating
an FDIC for investors and it wouldn't be
it would apply to every publicly traded
company like banks certain publicly
traded companies would have to qualify
first before they could be under that
program they and their brokerage and
analysts and others would fund that
program through a pool of money that
would be matched with with the federal
government so it wouldn't be all your
tax dollars coming back to rescue you if
they had charged a transaction costs
associated with all the trading they do
they're very quickly build up a sizeable
pool that'd be a limit to what you could
get you couldn't you could may not be
able to recover all of your investment
but unlike the Enron employees you would
not be left with a bunch of zeros in
your check balance you would have some
reasonable level of protection as it
turns out there are other countries in
the world who have sock Marcus who have
something very similar to an FDIC and we
think it's time that Congress seriously
took up this idea because we think it's
the one they have never talked about no
one ever wants to address I think the
final remarks I want to make and then
we'll open up for lots of questions
hopefully from you is that one of the
things that happen when President Bush
recently just gave his final remarks on
the corporate issues is that there seems
to be a call for cracking down hard on
the CEOs who are taking the money than
doing things and I think most of us feel
that way pretty strongly on the other
hand a side level that is that there is
great concern at least that I've raised
in the fact that as you start to show
that then to a person like yourself who
may be going out tomorrow and back to
work and you run across one of these
situations or you happen to be the chief
of an auditing team who is going back to
Rio de to company and you discover one
of these it's an enormous enormous
responsibility and we've just doubled
that problem by saying that we're going
to
we prosecute a prosecutor even harder
now what happens in is a real moral and
ethical decision it twice as big I think
then we had before which is wouldn't it
be easier if we could just work this
thing out somehow quietly versus some
type of a way that we could probably
somehow bring that open and I don't know
what kind of amnesty kind of thing but
after a certain period didn't say all
right now we're going to you know here's
your time you got six months get it
corrected or seriously else but what
we've done is we've dropped a hard
hammer down right now and if we could
debate this probably for many days but
it actually has a huge effect and I'm
actually very concerned about that
effect because we were just starting to
see things start to simmer up now this
next week or two we're going to see a
lot of quarterly reports come out the
markets are going to be brewing their
next quarterly reports and we're going
to see a lot of companies say that I'm
within two cents of our earnings
estimates or three cents hey come on you
all run your own checkbooks I mean
really if you took your own estimate
each month how close you were going to
get do you think you would do that we
know one of the things we discovered in
the book is that of the world's 100
largest economic entities 52 of them are
companies not countries and then to say
to us as educated investors that we're
within a penny of our estimates come on
the question is what is it and that's
the reality we don't know so in kind of
concluding this this piece and then
let's get to some question answers this
book while small thin and in some cases
even reviewed by people that say hey
whats new companies have been lying for
a long time ah not like this at least
not exposed like this that's what's new
and in here are some thoughts that go
very deep into the next generation of
our management science some of the
reforms we have to have and some of the
ethical issues by the way that we
believe have to be found in our
corporations so Larry anything else you
want to say I think
that wraps it up I'm anxious to hear
from the audience so we'd like to take
some questions please yes to the mic so
that our guests on c-span can also hear
the questions and so that we can speed
up the process I want it I'll start by
asking a question so that you can
respond to it while our friends are
getting to the mic the audience mike is
over here on my left and uh but I wanted
to ask you about why this is all of a
sudden coming out like this and why we
didn't know anything about it a year ago
or two years ago in three years ago well
obviously no Enron kind of broke open
the doors that was the kind of the model
case but if you go back as one of these
rich and I mentioned we were talking
your office as a culture we are we are
hard pressed to receive warning I mean
we go back in history and people say we
had the facts in our hands about Pearl
Harbor we fail to understand that we
were liable for an attack we now go back
and say well there's a lot of signs
about the World Trade Center situation
we didn't read that warning there was
warning all over the place prior to
Enron but as a culture as a national
culture we we don't look for that kind
of stuff we hope things well we had
questions even about Enron we had hedge
funds you know closing out their books
on Enron we had a reporter from fortune
magazine who wrote an article saying
there's something really squirrely going
on here we had of the 16 analysts who
tracked Enron only one said don't buy I
mean that right there we should have
seen to 15 of them are lined up and one
of them's not you know what's going on
but there are other there were more
detailed and specific kinds of what we
were not tuned we were not tuned up to
this kind of issue because kind of the
de Marville number one we were in shock
after World Trade Center prior to the
World Trade Center everyone was bopping
along in a very hot market and no one is
paying very much attention to these
things there's actually a couple other
different pieces of that one of them is
and I do a lot of work down the Houston
area you go down to Houston everybody
down there will tell you oh we knew this
a long time ago this was no big secret
in Ron's been doing this for years and
you sitting you go
if you knew that why didn't somebody say
something there's a big question there
in my mind about us as Americans and how
this stuff gets opened up and turned in
if it's going to be investigative
reporters only or are we individuals
doing this or are we relying on a
enormously understaffed sec to become
our enforcement agency because again you
can't chase the al-qaeda which we found
in the book here the complexity of those
monetary systems deal with an Enron deal
at MCI and five others of these coming
up with an enforcement agency as we have
and still review now the ones that are
being turned up now the bristol-myers
squibb's and some of the others by the
way I believe those are still just old
cases I think we're just resurrecting
things I don't think we have that that
much aggressive sec participation out
there right now looking at all the other
things going on as I said before because
who in their right mind is going to want
to expose this stuff it's really tough
issue question here yeah I have a chance
region will get so I don't quite know
what you mean by authenticity and I'd
like to have you elaborate on that and
then explain if you can how that relates
to an organization's policies and
structure and culture okay thank you you
take four shot 90 this is I mean this is
an idea that I repeat the question yeah
the question i think was about could
could I explain the idea of authenticity
as we talked about in the book and how
it relates to any company's policies and
and the way they conduct themselves I
think that's about the gist of it again
we came up with the idea of authenticity
being one of the next most important
corporate assets because now investors
want to see that they want we just want
to read the annual report they want to
really see some hard evidence that
company is conducting itself properly
now most of these companies they really
got into big trouble the tone was set at
the top the leadership always sets the
tone the moral tone the ethical tone and
so forth a set there to the point where
the employees the managers the chief
financial officer they know what they
can get it get
they know what's expected of them they
know what kind of pressures being placed
on them we're saying that the companies
that we observe and we do but it matter
of fact dedicate the book to the
thousands of companies who are doing it
right that's the book is dedicated to
the good companies because they set the
tone at the top and they let it be known
right from the beginning that this
company is not going to tolerate anybody
who gets close to the edge anybody who
cuts the corner anybody who lies or does
anything else wrong this is the nature
of our company warren buffett said this
is what he looks for when he interviews
the leadership team to the companies
that in which he makes his investments
so authenticity is a is a is an ethical
position that a company can take they
can take it it can be reflected in their
policy it has to be reflected in their
conduct from day to day where they will
not tolerate anything other than off the
authentic conduct in the course of their
business activity we believe that there
is a movement that needs to take place
in the boardrooms and across the
companies all over the place where
authenticity becomes highly valued and
it's highly rewarded the the nature of
actually how this gets billed though is
a very important thing because again you
can express authenticity in many
different ways can lay in his message
the shareholders in the front of the
annual report expressed an enormous
amount of compassion authenticity I mean
we compared that letter that he wrote to
a hundred other differ ones out there
and there is absolutely no difference
they all are completely the most
wonderful company in the world the ones
that do all these things that Larry just
talked about and so the worry we have
both of us as we do this the part we
believe the next generation of
management is going to have to get to is
try to distinguish between this fine
line between the public relations you ha
that goes on and the reality are we
really doing this now Larry's absolutely
right starts with number one and it
starts with the board and they've got to
come open they've got to disclose this
but then again we're asking people to do
things that even our Congress won't do
that many of our other leaders don't do
and we've got a very difficult issue
Congress wants transparency in corporate
America but Congress does not want train
perrin see on Capitol Hill I can
guarantee you that more questions okay
having spent a good deal of time in the
third world I'd always assumed that the
difference why the third world had
corruption and the West basically had a
rule of law was a cultural issue i have
seen where a western culture however has
been destroyed cousin from the czech
republic told me last year quote the
Communists taught us how to steal now my
fear is that your book illustrates a
deterioration of cultural values and
could you comment on whether this is a
valid concern you mean take the lead you
follow this one it is a very valid
concern it's a great question could you
all hear the question okay the issue of
culture is a very difficult one to
wrassle with we started to look at
various rankings that were done by
different organizations around the world
about who supposedly had the most clean
culture for doing business and
performing these things and it's quite
interested in the u.s. is in the top 10
but it's not in the top it's not in top
five Great Britain kind of the same way
but they were high except when they
dealt outside their own country of which
then they follow the local rules and
help keep those things as corrupt as
could be which by the way is a very
interesting issue because it is a
commentary on how we actually know to do
business it's not necessarily saying
those people in those other countries
want to continue to do business that way
and we have forced many of our large
corporations and such on that this will
be part of this cultural message that
will be written the other part of this
message that we believe culturally
inside here is the question of how long
will investors tolerate these
continual misgivings here before the
only response we have culturally to say
you can't do this is as people begin to
pull their money out of the market it's
the only thing actually the business
will understand at some point and until
that happens or until we see that I
don't expect there to be a lot of
cultural reform actually occur here but
there we've had many many times over the
number of years where the marketplace
has never had so many investors in the
markets before there's other investments
such as real estate and bonds and etc
and there's no reason to panic in any of
this but business is going to need some
time also to figure out what to do about
this that anybody who says this is going
to be solved and we've solved the
problem I followed a presentation that
the CEO of Xerox made recently that
history begins now we've now changed and
my comment was what are the five things
that Xerox is doing today that's
different than yesterday to tell us and
if so are you willing to sign a document
that potentially would put you of course
not and so when I when I see those
things to happening today I'm convinced
that our culture has some very serious
directions to have to deal with yeah I I
do think there's a problem I mean the
problem came to our minds as soon as we
got in this there's something you know
really wrong I really had never taken
the opportunity to kind of study that
issue until we got into this so one of
our follow-up pieces which we didn't
really write about as i looked and did
some research on there were business is
a national annual business ethic survey
so i went back and looked at those
surveys during the hot part of the
market back over the last four or five
years when all this stuff was really
going on all the ethics survey said
everything's fine no problem you know
we're really good now we dig down into
that people will if you would get on an
individual level people say well I'm
ethical but I'm not so sure about that
guy you know the other people have
ethical problem but I don't have ethical
problems I think there's some kind of a
disconnect that's evolved over time in
our culture by the way he was a
documentary this summer that we were
last summer I guess it was about lying
in American culture i think is ABC and
basically said is everybody's lying
about some
most of the time and not paying a whole
lot of attention to it not taking it
very seriously but I hope that there's
some way through this process that we're
going to take seriously again a look at
this business of ethics and what what is
it right to do because I think we do
have some sort of a national problem I
think we've been looking at other people
and say you know look over in Asia it so
it's always been a historic casino in
terms of stocks because these guys are
totally corrupt well now we here we see
in the European newspapers the fingers
pointing back over here and say we're
withdrawing our money from the American
markets because you guys can't get it
right I think we have reason to be
concerned one of the just one little
follow-up piece that comes with this is
and I've fortunately we've been out a
lot in the press here recently we had
between Larry I on thursday i think we
had 22 radio shows we were doing it just
in this one day there was a question
that both of us have surfaced and we
would ask this room to also surface the
question you know there is a definitely
a deafening silence from the business
schools and from the CEO organizations
okay really serious deafening silence
and the best I here on WTOP and some of
the other radio stations or Collins's
described us your ethics course that you
teach not not about how deep are these
endowments and how how how will this
affect you and can you come to the
rescue can you do things that will
create this and the same way with the
CEO forums and such Larry NAR going to
be speaking at the conference board up
in New York is fall and these are big
issues that we think but we're not
hearing the noise we're not hearing the
Harvard professors come out and talk
about this please touched on this on
your closing remarks there's this claim
that well there's always been lying
going on but you suggested there's a
qualitative change here but picking up
on that theme I've also heard it said
that well this always happens after you
know you have
a bunch of gogo years like we had during
the 90s and I'm wondering to what extent
you feel that what went on during that
period causes to happen or perhaps
brought it to the surface and would it
have been different had we had a more a
less Go Go period here we still be
seeing what we're seeing now yeah I mean
this is good question because try to put
some this in the historical perspective
one of the great books about the history
of this is the book called robber barons
I think was published in the 30s but it
tells the story going all the way back
shortly after the Civil War by the way
they were you know lay into the national
railways that was the Internet of the
19th century it caused a lot of chaos
and confusion in it it also created an
enormous wealth for a few people and and
the guys around the turn of the century
they were the real masters of how to get
away with stuff in the boardroom and in
the antitrust legislation so forth came
out during that time but we see these
cycles as you say the boom and bust
periods we see every decade has had a
nice little spike of fraud somewhere in
that this one seemed to be a little
different the magnitude of it and I
here's what we think because we had
moved into the internet our internet
period and the technology we had we had
an interesting convergence a very
complex and new exciting technologies of
global business on a scale that's never
ever occurred before in the history of
this planet under any kind of condition
that we can confine and then the
complexity of business transactions
within that setting this laid the
groundwork where businesses outran the
administrative and legal infrastructures
that had supported them for decades and
so it became the wild wild west during
that particular decade of the 90s the
accounting rules and regulations
underwent slight curious little
modifications one right after the other
so that pretty soon there was such a
kludge of accounting rules that
accounting truly became the Alice in
Wonderland situation where what I say
means exactly what I me just say it to
mean nothing more nothing less and you
could get away with anything I was
listening to
Arthur Levitt on the radio today they
played a little skit from our little
news clip for Arthur Levitt for all I
think was from Louis ruckheiser to the
night where a mutual fund manager said I
believe that 99% of the companies are
you know really good companies and
everything okay mr. Levitt would you
comment on that he said that that's not
right it says because there's because
there's a long list this guy who was on
enforcement business for a long time
there's a long list there's hundreds and
hundreds of restatements over the last
few years where companies have obviously
it's a kind of their way of admitting
you know we may have screwed this up but
we meant the very best thing you know
what we did it but they're within the
rules within exclusive rules all the
rest of the company's those who haven't
been caught can can use perfectly legal
ways to perfectly misrepresent the state
of their performance to you so in a way
our law ironically our law now protects
the ability of corporations to tell us
whatever they want to tell us and that's
that's another thing i think there's
quite different in this period that
we've gone through we think that
corporations by the way i'm just looking
over here on the wall at some of the
other business books primal leadership
okay the strategy machine i mean if you
just look at the titles of the books
they give you the impression that
somebody's creating stuff that this is
down at very gut level kind of operative
things that we're doing and quite
honestly it's true and that's why we
actually believe that business is got a
bright future ahead of it but it's going
to actually have to go through this
Reformation period and i don't think
it's going to be done by a few people
declaring we're going to restate and
then we're okay i think that that will
kind of fade into our American mindsets
for a while that ok Xerox did their
thing there okay now what we are Larry
and I actually believe and we've not
said too much about this we didn't talk
about this in the book yet but we're
trying to figure out if this is book too
is that we actually believe there's
going to be a lot of private placements
where public companies will no longer
remain public but if their stocks
actually get low enough that you're
going to see the goldman sachs and the
merrill lynch's net cetera develop new
investment arms which is where they used
to take companies into IPO
our public offerings they're actually
going to take these companies into
private offerings get them off the
market okay possibly clean them up and
then reissue them as new I POS where
they could make even more money out of
the the turnover that it's a great
country absolutely and the law
profession will help us lead through
many of these kinds of things you
mentioned there are some truly evil
people who rape and pillage companies
yes but how much of this problem is
caused by Wall Street placing
unrealistic expectations on companies
forcing them to buy out restate hide
things and cause what you just said
goldman sachs merrill lynch re buying
companies and re-issue in them it's it's
what we call the great Capitol Complex
not to take too far off on eisenhower's
military-industrial complex it's a huge
capital food chain you know that it
starts with the companies and their
underwriters the investment bankers that
brokers the analyst the pundits on TV
who are hyping these guys are all
working together the lobbyists and of
course the congressmen who have their
hands deep inside the pockets of Enron
you know worldcom all these guys are all
kind of link their extensions of each
other now the pressure is generated when
you're a CEO and every 90 days you have
to be able to stand up and say we did
what we said we're going to do we had a
forecast we're still going to do this we
did it if you say we didn't do it then
the market gives you a spanking no no no
you can't do that we're going to take
your stock down there for a while Warren
Buffett remarkable in time you know that
on the long holidays the market closes
down sometimes it's closed down three
four five days the world doesn't explode
when this is closed down and I think we
should get away from some of the
artificial pressures like the quarterly
report I'll be perfectly happy to see
companies reporting twice a year June in
December March October you pick it out
there'll always be enough reports to
talk about give us two good reports each
year just make damn sure they're right
and accurate and so that we can trust
them because we're going to be watching
your track record like never before so I
think you're a number of things we can
do along along the way to take off the
artificial price
and let companies get back to managing
their companies rather than managing
their stocks we actually believe this
managing the companies instead of
managing the stocks is the key most of
the things that we've seen in the future
in this book have to do with the way we
have developed financial engineering as
a product of the company rather than the
real product of the company and what's
happened is that we're out there selling
so many other things other than the
actual products we used to sell and
these are all part of this information
technology part of the financial systems
and etc and it's an unknown patan to
your question about the bad people there
are bad people still out there and
what's going to be really interesting to
watch is how they will transition
eventually out of the companies okay
because they all have these big packages
sitting there waiting okay there this
didn't go away again okay just because
we wished it would it's still there the
question will be will some of these
individuals manage their company toward
a fruition that actually makes the
change or will they try to leave in some
decent period of time where they can get
out and the next person come in who will
then want to expose something that
happened in order to place the blame on
the previous one so they're not going to
get on the hook because if you think
about being a CEO today anybody in their
right mind would not want to go do this
because the allegations potentially
against you coming in as we're seeing an
Enron occur there was a changeover
during that time still holds can lay
quite responsible for something that
maybe happened even a year ago too and
so the best method I've seen so far from
the bad people is for them to slowly try
to sneak out okay and turn it over but
if they happen to turn over to a really
smart guy or gosh they're going to end
up taking this and right back at that
person getting it off their chest so
it's going to be a very interesting good
guy bad guy who is that who is not we
won't know that for a while
I what indicators would you look for as
an investor to either jump in or jump
out of the market in addition to the
reforms that you have in your book and
what should the average person the
street who you know the average person
people who aren't a lot of people
invested in the market what should they
do given what's going on and what would
you look for is sort of measurements to
stay in or get out you want to go first
sure oh well I'll tell you what the
indicators are different I mean it's a
whole new ball game you don't look for
the magical checklist you know and and
when the chart gets up here you know the
guy on the TV they got all these stuff
come along the bottom of TV they got all
these nice charts they create the
illusion of you know cold calculated
precision about what's going on in the
market they're trying to call the market
as a sportscaster does a boxing match
blow-by-blow here's what's going on
that's totally unrealistic that's not
what the market does for us so here's
the indicator I want people to think
about is look at themselves first of all
before you get in the market I think
some people going to read this book and
there and they're going to say well I
should be in the market now I've got you
know I've got some tools to help me
through other people gonna read this
book say I don't belong anywhere close
to that marketplace it's not for me I
need to get out the first indicator to
look at about getting to the market is
your own education your own
understanding of the marketplace and
then your second thing to do which i
think is we suggest in the book is a
little different is you need to sit down
with your financial planner and your
broker or whoever you do the trading
weight and say look folks we are going
to get together and we are going to take
care of my money it's my money you're
not going to tell me everything to do
with it you're going to stand up as an
investor and say I want you to tell me
exactly how we're going to invest this
money I want you to tell me all the
details I need to know take charge of
your investing destiny rather than have
somebody turn your money for you left
and right but begin the first indicator
is your mentality and your emotional
state for getting into the market
there's no magic bullet out there I'm a
little different take on it because I'm
not quite as forceful with my broker is
that it's a it's somehow there is this
this eyeball to eyeball thing and I kind
of go
okay I'll trust you again but just don't
mess it up my feeling right now is that
you have to find we start early in the
book by talking about Las Vegas and a
comparison of Las Vegas to the market
and you know when I go into a casino or
something you know I don't gamble very
much but I'll take twenty dollars I put
it in my pocket I say when twenty
dollars up its up and I mean it and
that's kind of where I am as a person
right now and my indicator is my pain
threshold has gotten hit ok and because
of that I don't know in the next couple
years whether or not I can truly trust
my broker the companies were invested in
or any of those things at this point and
so until I see some kind of sign I've
got to go with something that's much
more realistic to me which may be a
piece of real estate which may be a
Treasury bill which may be a lower set
of interest issues but I just don't have
the tolerance to deal with it now that
way I can still talk to my if I have
somebody working with me say we'll just
move the money over here how about that
that's a that's a unique position now
just by the way watch that because they
can move it over into a higher charged
fun okay and they win even more so so
don't what I'm just moving over when you
do it you say i want to know load I mean
how complicated can it be for certain
parts of government bonds okay so just
you know watch that but my indicator is
right now and right now a lot of us need
to be making decisions and if you don't
know for sure you should spend the time
this is your money and people say yes
but the market average is itself out yes
but many of us may not live that long
okay Richard seriously why not bought a
bunch of new mattresses the other day no
I just wanted to talk about punishment
and crime I've construct for a long time
about the inequity between the the
punishment that people get who are at
the very low end of the economic totem
pole vis a vie those at the very top and
where he
a great deal now about having some
prison time for the distinguished CEOs I
wonder where you think that is going and
whether this push to really change some
of the disequilibrium between white
collar crime at the very highest levels
and street crime where in some states
three strikes and you're out you may be
in jail for your life is this really
going to go somewhere and can we expect
a greater equity in terms of the
punishments that those who are the high
rollers are going to be facing I'll take
the first answer to this question I
think Fox TV is going to have the best
Fear Factor show in the world if they
get a they get a CEO who's been making
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
and they actually put him in a real
penal institution I think fear factor
will just be the tip of that iceberg on
television okay they'll probably sell
the rights to it I actually can't
imagine in my mind how this is going to
work that if they do really jail these
people in real jails I mean think of
yourselves and how it would feel to have
made a hundred million dollars a year
and be put in jail for some period of
time I mean I actually think that that
could cause people to take their own
lives to do many many many things that
we've read about in history before when
we've come to this I think it's going to
be a very serious issue that when we
start to see these people really
punished and they are actually really
punished in real penal institutions that
we actually may see some reform even in
our penal institutions at that point
you're asked where this is going it kind
of reminds me the stuff that kind of
macho talk we hear from the Congress
today kind of reminds me of you know
when my kids were growing up I say you
come in late one more time and I'm gonna
ground you you know for three four days
well that didn't last very long and
that's not going to last very long
either and as I said before until the
policy side and the rule reform and the
legal infrastructure are integrated
together nothing's going to happen about
jail term the legal standards right now
for proving intent and so forth to get
one these guys behind bars is
almost impossible no one has gone to
jail yet in Ronda Enron guys are out
running around and they're not wearing
striped suits not not the kind you wear
in jail and they probably won't so we
got a long period to go through before
the legal infrastructure allows Harvey
pit and the sec guys to investigate and
prosecute and punish in a reasonable
fashion in the meantime we were left to
rely on the good companies out there to
set the example and figure out what we
need to do now right now pettis today
we're going to make them sign and
certify if they screw this up we won't
let them serve on any board or any other
officer position in a CEO so they're
going to punish by reputation attack and
as it that'll be it for a while cuz it's
going to take a long time for the law to
catch up to this if you stop and think
also about major criminals who have been
we haven't seen this white collar
criminal like this before I mean
normally have been associated with some
form of mafia or some type of a Milliken
was about the first one and you know I
don't think any of us really remember
that as hard time somehow in our mind
okay and as we begin to see this next
stages of things it is a very difficult
I mean it was a career move a career
difficult move for this gentleman and
such but I think that it's a scale that
we could be talking about you know with
a number of people from the Anderson
organization right now at risk and a
number of people from Enron at risk and
a number of people from all these
companies I mean this is a scale of
which is just a Dwarfs milliken
situation by by huge amounts huge
amounts next question authenticity is to
become an asset we anticipate that
accounting rules and procedures we have
to change in order for that to happen
and if so do you anticipate corporate
America promoting those changes instead
of resisting them in order to achieve
that authenticity yeah we're they're
definitely gonna have to change we're
going through the period of resistance
right now as soon as the business world
since that Congress might actually stand
up and do something the the lobbyists
were ginned up at high speed I mean
lobbyists were all over the hill and
they were telling the Congress now if
you guys make any reforms
make them quote business-friendly
remember where your campaign
contributions come from I mean if you
lock us all up who's going to bail you
out on the campaign side so there's a
lot of reform it has to be done there in
order they have to actually be
simplified right now they're so closed
up and there are complex business deals
out there that are just hard to set down
and in plain English some time but these
think you're going to have to go
together first of all we are depending
on some companies and some companies are
showing some signs of life in this area
that they are going to set the example
here's what authenticity looks like
here's how here's how you know that you
can trust what we're doing and what
we're saying we're going to disclose
more than we need to disclose we're
going to go beyond what the rules say in
order to make sure that our shareholders
are properly represented and so forth
authenticity is really an ideal that
we're holding up into the business
community right now whether or not this
really does become a standard corporate
asset is something we're going to have
to wait and see far something we're
going to push for we're going to hold it
out there is the flag for people to look
out as long as we can implementing this
concept of authenticity though is is
part of our next challenge to and
management I actually believe that the
technology is going to have to play a
major role in this because as we see the
SEC is never going to have the
enforcement agency to do anything more
than still randomly sampled most of our
major publicly traded corporations with
14,000 of them it's almost impossible
there there will have to be at some
point some direct linkages much more
than we currently have from the
reporting that we have companies
companies going directly into the SEC so
it can be monitored really in more real
time that's the only way we can see
other than absorbing many of the public
accounting firms as part of an SEC
overhaul and sending them out as field
troops but you know honestly as a kind
of an advanced thinker and management I
don't see that happening if we did that
we're setting herself back for many
years to come the real step will be when
the management teams start to realize
they actually do have the capability and
are willing to open up into the SEC
and allow this and then also to give
their governor their Board of Governors
tools if you stop and think about who
was on the board many folks don't know
how to use technology effectively
they're not trained into the school and
so when they receive the reports from
the management people I mean that's what
they're used to receiving and that's
management's story and it may be riding
it may be wrong i don't know but all i
know it's their story and so all the
board can do is interpret that story the
board needs tools they need the same
kind of tools that management has access
to to be able too much more
independently look at these kind of
things and they need to be able to ask
more what if kinds of questions and such
but right now that has been hampered too
and so again that's why I believe that
reform opportunities are there and
there's some tremendous opportunities
right now for companies to step forward
because I actually believe that if
companies will step forward and say look
we don't know whether we've done we have
no intent by the way of doing this I
mean I've had company safe look this
book should be on every employee's desk
just because I don't want anybody
walking around here thinking they can
walk up to any of our employees and say
do something that you shouldn't do I
want this book sitting there not as a
business book might be sitting there but
a business book that says don't come to
me and ask me to do bad things like this
one of the stories we didn't tell you at
the very beginning is this book had a
very interesting title before it was
written it was called mascot Iruka which
is a russian term for deceit and
deception and as some of you may know
that's part of the intelligence
community's discussion about how to
create a certain kind of cover-up where
the truth at some point can't be
distinguished from the lie and if you
tell the lie long enough it becomes the
truth and that's really where we are in
asking about how to interpret these
financial results how we as investors
the question earlier are supposed to
read signs it's hard for us to tell
because we don't know right now we're in
that period
I wanted you to elaborate a little more
on technology and its relationship to
money and particularly the way in which
money moves around the world so fast and
how you're going to stop this i mean
take an Enron with its off-balance sheet
companies operating in different time
zones you can make a lot of claims about
how much money a company has at a
particular time point in time and how
hard that is to audit and even to begin
to get a hold of I mean in my business
money all goes over the weekend of Hong
Kong and gets played out in the Middle
East I mean in the Far East and then
moves by time zones and his back on on
time in America at nine o'clock eastern
standard time but people are doing all
kinds of things with money at different
times so I'd like to see and you touched
on it before when you said we have to
peek into this but that's a very fast
rating racing a situation well we both
have comments so Larry you start on this
one well that's one of the that's one of
the big discoveries not it's not a real
big discovery for a lot of people goes
been going on for a long time but every
well just to give it a little context
tonight for example hundreds of billions
of dollars are moving around these
financial networks between here London
Hong Kong Singapore and other places
some of that's your money some of it's
money that you're obligated to pay for
but it is an incredibly complex global
financial network right now that really
drives the capital markets both here and
in Europe and in Asia and these this
complexity and the technologies that
support it have created the hiding
places and the tools for hiding money
transactions and so forth and businesses
can manage their performance based on
their ability to use technology to
maneuver these financial networks now
there's a lot more to be said about that
and I think there's probably a couple of
books that will be coming out within the
next few months that talk specifically
about how that goes on but it is really
an incredible complicated situation
there's elements of if you want to get a
little bit ahead on that there's
elements of the next generation of
technology which is the software agents
the actual programming pieces that can
accompany money remember when money
turns digital it's just a series of
programming
and you can attach any kind of other
pieces and so they can be accompanied by
guards it can be accompanied by agents
that actually do stuff with it other
words there's instructions for the money
to perform it's not like in our wallet
this is something that's kind of dead it
doesn't perform that thing that travels
around the world performs its performing
based on the instructions that accompany
it it can become a company and register
itself and deregister or unregister
itself in various countries and the
things that I have concerned about in
the next generations is that we've had
numerous technology books talking about
this technology curve and how fast
technology space of changes if we have
to wait five years six years for major
reform to occur that's three turns of
this thing they call Moore's Law that's
the doubling of the technologies
capability every 18 months that's three
Exponential's on top of what we have
this is extremely nerve-racking for me
as being kind of a future technology
person I worry about this probably more
than anything because the creation of
these entities in cyberspace where you
have countries like Belize and etc who
can create favorable situations for
business to exist those businesses
aren't moving physical people to those
countries they will be moving the
digital money and the digital structures
that surround that money to those
countries that's that's the real rub and
this by the way you've hit on it this is
one of the reasons Larry and I put the
stake in the ground that's why this book
was set as a mission right now to say
wait a minute before six more years turn
or ten years we got to do something now
because if it's this bad under our
current way I can't imagine what it's
going to feel like if we don't recognize
this in the future it's just a closing
comment in terms of what the reforms
that are going on right now do not
address this in any way the ability of
devotees of the essay
he does have do not address this there
they have almost zero capability to
understand this so the reforms we're
doing right now we reacting to things as
they were three years ago in the
meantime the clock is spinning ahead and
these networks are going to make life
really interesting are we done well I
think we have one more question do we
have over here we have one more we have
one more question please first of all
thank you very much for coming and for
writing this very timely book the
question I have looks I guess in many
ways the people some of the people who I
work with and who have been taught by
and when I was in school now finished
sit on many boards when I say many five
some of them said on foot 10 even 12
boards my question to them is first of
all what you do second of all how were
you contacted to sit on each one of
these boards at the end of each meeting
you know why money is wired to a private
accounts etc things of that sort but my
question to them really goes more to the
heart in the core matter of each of
these companies they sit on what do they
know about the company's what are the
ethical values the morals the tone that
sets of these companies what are we
doing to begin to change this type of
dynamic what are we doing in terms of
the management board you say leadership
starts at the top with the CEO with the
board are we holding our boards
accountable I just signed for example
today is live from a MicroStrategy
approve approve approve 4444 vote for
this well for that and for the I'm sorry
they're meeting that they're having I
think in two weeks time in signing and
checking off and everything I had no
idea what I was checking off who are
these people what do they stand for and
what mechanisms can be placed two really
little bit deeper into that your
questions I'll take the first one you do
it you know I did exactly the same thing
this last week I don't know how many of
you get proxy statements that come in
the mail but for the first time I
actually looked at mine and it was
appalling to me it was at first of all I
know nothing about all these people that
they have at least said we get on the
web and do all this they don't really
mean for me to do that that's just just
not working it absolutely is it's a form
secondly I there was actually a folder
that
did give some description about each of
the directors who are I saw a couple of
them had 17 boards they sat on excuse me
I mean no I don't want this person
representing me 17 boards how could they
possibly do their due diligence one of
the pieces in the book we talk about in
dysfunctional governance is that we
actually believe some point there will
be professional board seats people who
actually are trained to be on a board
raise contentious issues and not worry
about the peer pressures that surround
them on the board because the issues
that board members face everything from
their personal homes that they have
loans from to a whole series of stock
and other pieces and it's gotten to the
point where we can't operate like this
and to say well we're going to have
independent board members outside more
if you've ever sent in a group of people
and even if it's a deciding what kind of
coffee you want to drink if you're the
descendant you're out you don't like
that and you want to hold your own or
look at a jury that hangs I mean the
worst fear is to be the one person that
believes so strongly while the rest of
your think what it's like when you're
dealing with a multiple Global
billion-dollar business that by the way
many countries depend upon presence if
you take some of these companies and you
shock them inside these countries the
countries economies will crumble there's
some big deep issues here and there not
resolved just by ethically do I believe
this because the move is too big just
from the ethics there was a great
question I was four years of senior
partner in hydrating struggles which is
an executive search firm and we we
search for these bored people we were
had the mandate from corporations to go
out and find competent board members so
there are a lot of boards out there are
a lot of companies who take this very
seriously they want people who are
competent in the work they're going to
ask the board member to do they have
good board processes good board
practices they have independent members
of the board they have governance
committees and Audit Committee and
compensation committee that knows how to
make sure that the board is doing the
job right and they take the title
trustee very very seriously
unfortunately there are way too many
publicly traded companies have boards
made up of their good old boy good old
girl network who slap each other on the
back you know go take four or five
resolutions make a vote get some lunch
go play golf and they're gone and that's
it that's that's what they do for you
zero they are the under performing asset
of the corporation by and large
directors are we point out in the book
is that investors are going to have to
learn more and that's what this chapter
is all about we want we want you to know
exactly what goes on and what should go
on in the boardroom and we really talked
a lot about the next generation of board
members and what they need to look like
and how you as investors off to relate
to them and be able to call them up and
ask them questions and and have a
dialogue if you're a real serious
investor yes I just want to draw some
conclusion then to this for a moment you
say well how can you get all this in
this book well we didn't what we try to
do was again timing was not in our mind
what we were writing a year ago was a
book that saw many of these things as
you hear us speak right now you know
that this isn't about trying to rush a
book out to hit a timing market we've
hardly spoken about Enron this is about
some very serious management principles
and management issues that Larry and I
feel very strongly about and that's why
this book was written we were fortunate
or unfortunate depend upon looking at my
checking account to be in a marketplace
it actually resonated with what we were
saying and in fact the books timing will
reflect that but this just begins to
touch and in fact this book is really
the tip of the iceberg for the
conversations thank you
I want to say one thing that I should
have said in introducing the the book
that I these guys their livelihood
depends on the people that they're
working that they're writing about so
it's a really courageous book as well as
being a timely book a thoughtful book
and so I really think that we need to
commend the authors I know this has just
been a fantastic discussion and the book
of course is how companies lie and the
authors are Larry Elliot and Richard
Strauss and I want to thank them both
for being here today and Larry Elliot is
president and CEO of EDA incorporated an
electrical engineering company Richard
straw thiz a corporate consultant
specializing in emerging technology and
business strategy how companies lie is
published by Crown business and imprint
of Random House visit crown business com
for more information